welcome back to cbs this morning new
government guidance is
raising doubt about the accuracy of
coronavirus
antibody tests the cdc says the tests
used to determine if people have been
infected in the past
could be wrong up to half the time it
recommends they not be used to decide
who returns to work this comes as two
major testing companies quest
diagnostics and lab core are rolling out
expanded testing programs in our
collaboration with the journalism
company clear health costs
consumer investigative correspondent
anna werner has been looking into those
programs
anna what have you learned
well anthony as you know antibody tests
will not tell you if you have an
active infection they tell you if you
may have had a past
infection as part of an overall program
a major testing company is now offering
those antibody tests
to anyone who wants one including
employers but is that a good idea
we feel really lucky that we've
recovered and you know it's behind
us lisa wagner and her husband maddie
goldberg fell
ill from coronavirus in march in april
they had antibody tests before visiting
her elderly parents
they came back positive we feel a little
bit like we have a superpower
but only within you know not a hundred
percent
so you're more confident now definitely
for now i
feel like i have some immunity many
people want antibody tests and major
testing companies including quest
laboratories are now
offering them quest launched a program
this week for employers that it calls
return to work
which includes those antibody tests one
company signing up
holiday retirement which runs 261
independent living communities for
seniors nationwide
ceo lily donahue wants to test her 8
000 employees frankly if you know that
most of your
employees are tested positive for
the immunity you may prioritize how
that person works right she hopes the
program will help her figure out how
best to deploy them
so if you have a positive case in your
community where there's a resident that
has coveted
it may make sense for that immunity or
you know the person who tested positive
to be doing more of the interaction and
quest chief medical officer dr jay
wolgemuth told us
the tests are useful once we identify a
person
who has a positive antibody test
and we've determined that they are not
currently
infected with the virus we now know that
that person
is very unlikely to bring
the virus with them into the workplace
quest is also now offering antibody
tests
on demand to consumers on its website
for 119
dollars plus a 10 dollar service fee in
marketing emails like this one the
company calls the test an immune
response blood test
and says understanding this gives you
insight on whether it's right to return
to work
school and activity do you agree with
that statement
i don't agree with that statement he's
michael osterholm who heads the
university of minnesota's center for
infectious disease research and policy
many of the individuals who end up being
test positive are going to be false
positive
meaning that they don't really have the
antibody even if you do have it
we don't know what it means yet and so i
think it's very premature to market
these tests like this
and i think that it's almost preying on
the vulnerability of the public today
preying on them you say because i did
yeah i think selling antibiotic tests to
the general public right now is just
plain wrong
but quest's dr wogemuth disagrees he
says the tests his company uses are
clinically validated and appropriate
so how would you respond to somebody who
says look it looks like quest
also saw a lucrative business
opportunity here
yeah i mean we've been uh responding to
this uh pandemic in a way
which is i think quite selfless and is
is motivated by
making a difference for the pandemic i'm
just wondering if people might get the
wrong impression when you say
it's going to give you insight on
whether you can return
yeah i think it absolutely can't
does provide insight to an individual
whether they're likely to bring a virus
into the workplace or not
i think we need to be clear that
this testing is not used to determine
uh who goes back and who does not go
back to work
so you know to your point if if there is
any language there that that
appears to indicate that then that's
something that we would uh
remedy
regarding that marketing the company
later told us that it does
indicate that the information on testing
should be used as part of a holistic
decision looking at several factors in
any work environment
quest also says that consumers will have
physician oversight as part of that
process
it says the test can be helpful for both
individuals and
employers if they're considered in the
proper context
one interesting side note about all of
this we spoke with our medical
contributor
dr david agus who told us that he does
not recommend to his patients
that they get immunity or i should say
antibody tests
because he can't tell them if they have
any immunity
now if you have a coronavirus medical
story to tell us you can email us
email email health costs at cbsnews.com
anthony yeah it's really confusing when
the doctors disagree anna i
don't know quite what to make of what
that test tells you thank you very much